I knew this about you but if I didn't I
would have guessed it that you started
in standup because you're very quick
you're very funny and I'm just curious
when you start it out and stand up you
just went right for it and you had to
develop a pretty thick skin initially
before you found your Barre yeah I mean
I actually think that stand-up is
probably the best way to develop a thick
skin because pretty much the first three
to five years or just people not you
don't have to wonder if people don't
like you they will just tell you to your
face I don't care for you I don't take
something off entertain me you know and
then no one's ever asked me to take
anything off how badly things right
that's your own cross it bear yeah maybe
the tie yeah yeah and I but I think it's
great because I think as a stand-up what
you develop is this ability to not care
what people think you get this kind of
radical bravery and then also you
develop a really robust drinking problem
and that makes everything go away so you
know what you call it problem I call it
a solution what was the worst was there
ever a point where you thought okay I'm
up on this stage and these people aren't
just booing but it's it's almost worse
than that I was lucky because I had been
a sketch comic in high school in college
so I I did okay right off it wasn't
leather like my misery but I did do this
college tour and you know just we'd go
to these like you know local colleges on
a Friday night where the kids had been
drinking and they didn't even know what
you were there I did a show at a
Technical Institute once at lunchtime
where I stood on a table just screaming
jokes at people you know if they went by
with trays of like you know whatever I
don't know macaroni or humor right and
and I remember at one point someone's
like someone complained there's a black
girl screaming at us in the cafeteria
and we had another show where they
decided to combine pizza night with
comedy which is a terrible combination
of factors because a pizza uneaten is
just a really like yummy frisbee you're
sure though they were just like how
people were throwing up frisbees I mean
throwing pizza yeah with Richards
they thought I was insulted but i was so
broke it was I was like oh this is
awesome guys
we ate four like this yeah
don't need a refrigerator PITA
you